george clooney sounds off on the rust
tragedy welcome to entertainment tonight
everybody 26 days after cinematographer
helena hutchins was killed on set george
is adding his voice to the hollywood
outcry
it's infuriating
single time i'm handed a gun on a set
every time they hand me a gun i look at
i open it i show it to the person i'm
pointing it to show it to the crew
everyone does it everybody knows and
maybe alec did that i hopefully he did
do that
a 24 year old person with that little
experience shouldn't be heading up a
department with guns and bullets on
clooney doesn't hold back saying a lot
of stupid mistakes led to the rush
shooting and he's closely connected to
other onset tragedies in the past
i was friends with an actor named john
eric hexham who accidentally pulled a
gun up with blanket and put it to his
head and
died from the concussion and then i was
good friends really good friends with
brandon lee and that was a series of
stupid things the 60 year old actor is
also talking fatherhood telling mark
maron about the moment he and amal
decided to have kids we'd been married
for about a year and the mall said we're
awfully lucky in life and she said it
seems like that luck should be shared
with some other you know folks and i
thought about it for i don't know maybe
a minute then i just said well i'm in if
you're in and she said i think we should
try
how was quarantine with your children
because for a lot of us it was a real
adventure our kids are four and they
were two and a half when it started so i
didn't have to teach him trigonometry at
home
how is he as a teacher
oh he's great he's mainly teaching
pranks for the time being but we'll see
if it developed well i think those can
really pay off over time
[Music]